play on
well when he's got a cold for example
and you know when he's physically not
that well definitely impacts his
performance I mean if you look at his
performance as tournaments I actually
mean for his standards pretty poor yeah
um I think the cold has had something to
do with it so and he's just gonna have
to hope that that's still lingering but
just to reflect on on what David was
saying I see absolutely zero zero
Universe in which Anish goes for it in
this game uh he is going to try and find
a way to bore his way to a draw critical
moment we're ready got a spicy opening
though so ivanka's opening it is it is
my it's my karakan and Anish has chosen
a quite a dynamic line called the
panovynic and here it's in magnus's
hands what does he want to do does he
want to develop the light Square bishop
and take it into an end game and now he
kind of goes for one of these moves that
is the specialty of the English
Grandmaster Jonathan Spillman
yeah so Black's a pawn push quite rare
in general and there are more popular
Alternatives but he has encouraged a
niche to clarify the center and uh it's
another isolated Queen spawn that's the
theme of the day for Anish giri today uh
so far and pressure on the Black Knight
what would you do here Ivanka you're the
resident karakan expert that night in
the center would you move it would you
exchange it off for white tonight or
would you maybe just solidify it
probably would solidify it although I
don't actually play this particular line
but I can see that you can develop the
dark Square light Square bishop or you
can just uh push Pawn forward but uh
just checking my database I'm going to
check and see what the most popular move
is
develop the light Square bishop and
reinforce the Knight
yeah and we should mention Magnus he's
played the caracon in the past but
actually with very mixed results his 125
game unbeaten streak a couple of years
ago was ended by Duda in the caracon
he's played the caracon on various
occasions in the tour
um I remember a couple of defeats there
as well as some decent wins but I'm
pretty sure he hasn't had this exact
position before Magnus no I'm pretty
sure he he hasn't uh the database
certainly confirms that but uh I do
remember Magnus streaming and uh he he
played the caracon and afterwards he
said I really should not play this
opening it doesn't suit me at all and I
was like okay Miss Magnus I take your
point yeah I don't understand because it
it kind of it's right up the street
right karakan you get genuine generally
you get a good Pawn structure you get
healthy pieces very solid based
Foundation to work from but yeah Magnus
somehow results far worse than In the
Sicilian in the Kingsport openings
from what we've seen and okay he does
defend his night with the ball rather
than a bishop
but now white has a slightly better
version of some other main lines black
is wasted time on this Pawn push on the
edge of the board so
I'm not a huge fan of what Magnus is
doing like you said uh Lawrence Anish he
has a safety net he can take that black
knight in the center of the board at
some point if he wants and the pull
structure will be completely symmetrical
all right we already have a shocking
result here is around 14. it's a very
quick draw between Richard report which
we can understand and read it and this
is we did reacting to that super quick
draw he played with the black pieces so
I don't know if Richard report made it
just uh impossible not to go into that
look and read it because we did
obviously is right outside top 80 needs
to win his games but I don't get his
reaction at all I mean he played A
variation where white can force the draw
so he's only got himself to blame I mean
he played a Berlin defense if if you're
if you want to win a game don't play the
Berlin defenses black you can't be upset
Richard did the smart thing he secured
his
top eight position because Richard still
was
okay he was more or less in but this is
a hundred percent in so I have no idea
what what vidit is doing actually can
somebody explain it to me yeah I mean he
plays pretty much everything as black he
plays every opening so yeah I agree
Lawrence even if you've prepared the
Berlin defense for this tournament you
have to adapt according to the two
understanding exactly
um so okay he can argue he was black he
reported a fighting player he didn't
expect it but Rapport did this against a
niche just a few a few games ago
yesterday so it was to be expected
um if he'd done his preparation video he
would have known the report is ready to
do this
also you know he would have uh if you
check the results as well he would have
seen that Rapport had beaten Eric icy
and just needed to Coast the last two
games to secure a place and of course
Vita is in a must-win situation so it
was 100 obvious that report would do
this yeah it's the Practical thing to do
he did it yesterday I mean if you look
at your opponent's games in just this
tournament you know what openings
they're playing you know reporters
forced to draw like that so so Veda
could have played something completely
else with the black pieces to make sure
this wasn't the result just anything I
mean look at what Magnus has been doing
he's been playing all these funky
moderns and French defenses where there
are no well very few four straws but
vidit played the most well-known
four-straw variation in modern chess so
I I don't know if he didn't look at the
standings I have absolutely no idea why
he decided to play that opening and now
he's in big danger I don't what is he's
one of the best prepared players in the
world with it in other openings uh yeah
it's just a strange Choice yeah and I'm
a big fan of video I just want to point
that out there I absolutely love I
absolutely huge respect for video I
really get on with him I think he's an
asset for chess I think he's a great
Ambassador for Indian chess but I think
his reaction is uh is inappropriate
and here now has 18 points with only one
point in that game against Richard
report that means he is still outside
top eight if he would have won this game
he would be on 20 points he could go
past Anish giri and now he has David
Anton chasing from behind Vincent kaimer
and Daniel noraditsky chasing from
behind with only one round left to play
for we did these other players are still
fighting in round 14.
wow actually I'm just looking at the
previous results and now Anish giri if
he draws against Magnus and if he draws
the final game against Arjun he's safe
because he beat Vida in their head to
head so vidit's fate is um I mean he's
relying now on Magnus doing him a huge
favor
but this type of opening it's going to
be hard for Magnus to win if Anish has
peaceful intentions I wonder if Anish is
aware of those results actually if it
Anton wins the two final games
he will be on 22.
yeah so then it's not enough for a niche
with two drawers Ah that's true that's
true okay so David Anton is the main
Contender now maybe yeah rather than
rather than vidit
so okay Anish meanwhile retreating his
Bishop the bishop was vulnerable on the
Square is still the isolated Queen's
pawn and uh here contrasted to the last
game where Anish had an iqp as black all
the pieces were traded off there and he
was suffering for a long time against
David Anton now all the pieces are still
on the board
big difference and Black's night now
harassing the white light squared Bishop
which is quite a key piece
I think Anish will drop that Bishop back
but I have to say I'm not impressed by
Magnus here at all I mean I've done a
lot of work on these positions I've got
a number of students who play C3
Sicilians and and that sort of thing
this kind of setup can really lead to
very dangerous positions for black for
example you drop the bishop back to C2
and then if black plays a move like B5
you can play a very quick Queen D3 and
then you're lining up that battery
towards the black king and this is
particularly dangerous because
um you know if you ignore this and this
could legitimately just be on the board
let's say you play a move like Bishop to
B7 here you're very close to to just
losing immediately
but it doesn't quite work I think you're
just okay here as black I wanted to try
the move D5 of course to try and
uh to try and uh deflect the Knight away
from F6 so you're just in time but even
in this position you don't have to go
Queen D3 you've got 95 as a move you've
also got the square Bishop going G5 and
uh black has to set up the wall
formation with pawns uh that's when uh
the pawns put themselves on in light
squares and make a zigzag
and uh yeah we might well see this yeah
I think we'll probably get it I mean
it's been seen in a number of famous
games as well yeah I I expect Bishop G5
here G6 and then I expect uh Bishop H6
hitting the Rook rookie 8 and 95 and
then
suddenly all the sacrifices uh become a
real Knight takes G6 Rook takes E6 for
example so it starts to exist it could
it could be an issue's gold his uh his
uh what they call it Evergreen game of
this tournament If he if you remember
what Shaq has done right so far
sacrifice ignites Rooks Queens this is
exactly the sort of position Kaya where
you can do exactly that with white and
remember we've been talking about the
isolated Queen's Pawn this is exactly
the sort of setup you want
when you have the isolated Queen's Pawn
as the attacker all the pieces on great
squares for your pieces great mobility
and then at the right moment you just
find a way to break through that uh that
Fortress but maybe not anisha's style
that's the only one not an issue style
but he understands he
that he also understands that he he you
know this is the position that you have
to play like this so and this is the
current position the one thing that
makes me slightly skeptical of an issu's
chance this is the fact that earlier he
wasted a move playing this Pawn push
it's like why yeah I just you could have
used that to develop your Bishop a bit
earlier on you could have used it to get
your Rook into the game a bit earlier
and he's just playing a bit safe a bit
when did he play that actually it was
just a few moves ago so it was in this
position after black had castled he just
played this point yeah this is a really
weird move because you might give your
kings some space but the back rank isn't
really a concern and actually you
deprive a key Square for your pieces
often the queen can float the H3 Square
uh a rook can float there this is
actually a impedes the white position
often you push this Pawn Yeah whole way
forward
um initia I mean this is basically like
you said you mentioned the C3 Sicilian
it's basically a transposition to some
of those lines it's a caracon but you're
one tempo up uh as white and uh it's
also similar to a line of the um slav
but you just drop your Bishop back
that's the main move and you basically
have the same position as you do in the
game but you've got an extra time you've
got extra time because you saved on this
really useless move so it's actually
totally inexplicable by the way this
move it's in my opinion this is a like
if you ask Anish what after the game
what is H3 let's say he's in a good mood
and he wants to talk H3 is just you know
what he wants to do Lawrence for example
if black just Waits yeah he just wants
to take in the center and drop his
Bishop back and now this the black
Bishop can't come out and here he would
be playing for a draw so I think that's
that's so much of this such a strange
approach it's just not seen in any
literature anywhere on this subject
but okay game position is this one and
we're expecting Anish to try and attack
maybe bring his Bishop out but
is it his type of position that's the
big question
I think to be honest when you're Anish
Geary number four or five in the world
you should be able to play these
positions it is a uh I'd say it's it's a
well-known structure it's a well-known
position thousands of games
and uh I think to
to be at that level you have to know how
to play this position I think his move
here for example is completely fine is
it a chance for him to really prove
himself against uh critics yeah possibly
um I mean the Finish wins this then
he'll be full of confidence for The
Knockouts
um pretty much guaranteeing his spot
there
you mentioned this move is fine but I
like black circle yeah Knight dropping
back and now you basically have to trade
Knights because Black's Knight also
wants to jump to the B4 Square hitting
the White Queen hitting white slight
Square Bishop
and as we mentioned in the last game
exchanging pieces when you have an
isolated Queen's Pawn it's not a step in
the right direction
um he's not worse far from it with white
but at least I don't think he's better
either
um I don't think it's what he could have
achieved after like you said Magnus is
slightly hesitant opening
yeah and this idea was seen by aronian
the Black Knight retreating just a few
days ago in the US championship and
there was a very quick draw in one of
aronian's games in very similar
circumstances
so Anish will be will have been aware of
this night Retreat being an option for
black
want to play Knight G4 here is this his
weird idea uh going for checkmate yeah
so Black's night dropping back uh yeah
pressure on the night pressure on the
pawn and you want to drop the Knight
back here hoping for Knight takes night
and then Queen ticks would be checkmate
he's not gonna fall for that Magnus nah
so I guess the idea if the Knight does
drop back would be to
go for this Stone what did you call it
Ivanka the wall the wall whenever I set
it up because I I kind of play these
positions a lot whenever I set it up I'm
like solid I know I'm weak on the dark
squares but that doesn't matter and
instead yeah it's a nice term it is a
nice term the zigzag wall
instead he takes Knights off the board
is it like a wall with um what do you
call it presents you have electric uh
electric fence yeah or like yeah just
pointing at the top of them guess what
we're gonna see now
uh we just see it now on the board yeah
yeah no it's in operation and the bad
news for Gary is that a set of knights
have left the board and that night was
very important in uh destabilizing
blacks defensive resources on the right
now
I like Black's position I'll be honest
with you I think Magnus will like his
position as well I mean you can try to
initiate another set of Trades
yeah you can even kick away the White
Knight sometimes yep black has a few
easy moves you just centralize your Rook
you maybe move your queen out the way
somewhere then you bring your other Rook
towards the center okay well Anisha is a
switching tuck he is deciding he
relocates his bishop and perhaps
there's going to be some kind of
sacrifice on the E6 Square unlikely but
more likely is uh actually to push the D
Pawn one square forward yeah you're
right David he's in a drawing mood yeah
I mean this position I can understand
why he's in a drawing mood but uh maybe
some missed opportunities and I think
anisha's a bit nervous he's failed to
qualify several times this season for
The Knockouts he spent a lot of time on
the clock it's move 18 but he's down he
spent half his time
and yeah you're right if he plays this
move there'll be a bunch of exchanges
most likely equality Magnus doesn't want
to allow that though Magnus wants to
fight and he kicks away the white knight
from defending this Central post so now
the Knight has to move to a bit of an
odd Square
and uh yeah still very tense Anish
unable to get pieces off the board I
don't think he'll be happy with the
outcome oh yeah I mean it's no surprise
the Knight is on a bad Square
but I mean are there some tricks
looks like there are tricks you can you
well I think Magnus missed a spot could
he have played Bishop A4 there you want
to take this bishop yeah and go Queen A5
and attack both Bishops double attack
hitting this one hitting this one this
would force white to trade off another
set of pieces and actually the blacks
Bishop is far better than White's whites
is bad and this is all clear weakness
think you're right Learners that was
surely the reason why the evaluation bar
showed up for black very surprised that
Magna spent so little time on that move
because it felt like a moment where you
actually had to invest
a bit more to clarify things and now
okay you give white half a move yeah I
can understand Magnus kind of playing
immediately if there's another natural
alternative but this is hardly natural
this Rook move I guess he wants to swing
across
start attacking the weak isolated one
it's a missed opportunity and that's
where it again just uh for super Grand
Masters having the evaluation bar is so
important if Magnus had saw had seen
that the evaluation bar went to oh 0.8
for black he would instantly have known
okay there's something direct but he
wasn't
uh he's not privy to that information
so okay let's go back to the game
Anish under clock pressure
not easy for him no seven minutes down
on the clock if he loses this game he
will be so nervous heading into round
15.
and this is what tends to happen
actually even though Magnus might not
have played objectively the best move
there that the momentum swings in these
isolated Pawn positions are quite
drastic if your attack suddenly stops
working like it has here for an issue
you've got a knight on A4 which is a bit
awkward loose Bishop on G5 your G2
square is very vulnerable to some some
shots you suddenly go on the back foot
here and you're playing Magnus Carlsen
and suddenly you're like oh I'm a lot
worse oh he's defended everything oh
he's won my D4 pawn and I'm gonna lose
an ending and that is a legitimate
scenario now I really
I think
Anish didn't didn't show too much uh
experience actually it felt like to me
that he's just not that well well he's
not used to playing these positions with
white even though of course he's a
phenomenal genius he hasn't probably had
this because I think most players would
have gone Bishop G5 G6 Bishop H6 95 and
not allowed this this trade of of pieces
so I showed earlier yeah yeah
and again maybe it's just a repertoire
thing a niche likes to have openings
where he has a solid foundation here
it's not a solid Pawn structure for
white again and he's playing maybe the
most obvious move improving his worst
place piece The Rook
but maybe it doesn't get to the heart of
the position he has to be active because
long term isolated porn yeah Niles also
wonder whether magnus's uh Sly Rook move
also had another hidden purpose to it
maybe to line up the queen and the light
Square Bishop on the same diagonal and
start hitting at the pawn next to the
white king yeah the black queen could go
into the corner it looks constituted but
you're right Ivanka it's quite a typical
idea in these types of positions when
you have a feeling coated Bishop a queen
often helps it uh helps it gain power
lined up behind so we'll see what Magnus
does but yeah I mean if Anish doesn't
qualify now for The Knockouts
yesterday's decisions I mean it reminded
me I was at home last night just
thinking and I was like actually there's
been a few situations in my career when
I was younger that I made similar
decisions to a niche I was leading the
European championship in 2017 by half a
point three rounds left
I was a bit unwell so I took a quick
quick ish draw with white about 20 moves
and then I lost my next one and I
thought okay that's Connor I deserve
that and the same British Championship
one year I was really unwell but I was
leading so I took a quickest draw with
black so against one of my main Rivals I
thought that's a decent result next day
I got punished immediately so it's it's
just I don't know if it's the chess gods
or whether it's our own minds but
he'll have a guilty conscience and ish
about his decisions yesterday and that
might affect his moves now and uh okay
Black's night parking itself yeah in the
center very sensible it's very sensible
I have to say just to add to David's
point I think it's in our own minds to
be honest because we see you're not
religious believing in the chess Gods
yeah I believe in the chess gods
let me just clarify that
but but I mean I was thinking about
other players you know I mean I I think
those people who like Fighting Chess and
John Wall I think they will feel guilty
and it will have an impact on them so do
you have other pragmatic players like
Wesley so you know who knows how to just
uh
play professional chess at the right
moment and then he knows also when to go
forth and attack
and it works very well for Wesley
yeah it does it works very very well and
uh meanwhile Magnus has made a couple of
um very decent moves but white now has
got his Knight into a better square and
Magnus trying to trade off the dot Squad
Bishops they do leave the board some big
threats against the white king now you
have to be very careful the black
Queen's active
what do you guys think sensible stuff
from a niche so far but he needs a good
move now right he's going to play Queen
G3 here 100 I think he's going to try
and swap off yes maybe the White Knight
could step back and attack the black
queen uh I think attack the queen
but way too risky to try not to play
Queen G3 yeah end game against Magnus
with the worst Pawn structure
yeah but I mean Magnus has the better
pieces there's everything there no you
don't want to touch that keep keep the
agree with David attack attack the queen
yeah
um we can show those two options right
now that we're considering both of them
would be to do with this black queen
there are some indirect threats against
this Pawn now uh the Bishop from afar uh
lining up if white were to play a
terrible move here then the Black Knight
would come in and this would be
disastrous hitting the Pawn this way
this way and this way three times and
this would end in a Black Wind simply so
black uh White NOW anishagiri needs to
stop that Lawrence is suggesting this
queen move makes a lot of sense getting
the Queens off the board
um it's probably roughly level but I'm
just slightly skeptical that Anish will
go for this because this Pawn could be a
weakness long term I think Magnus would
love massaging an advantage in the same
game later on if you can the other
alternative would be to attack the queen
kick her away
uh either with a rook I'm not sure this
looks a bit
official or with the Knight
to force her to retreat but I mean
wherever she goes she doesn't even need
to retreat maybe she'll just park
herself on the edge of the board plaque
still has control over most of the
important squares
black has obvious moves as well but I
can push a pawn black can centralizes
Rooks later black and move his King I'm
not sure what white does well in the
meantime okay Anish does go with the
Rook needed to kick the queen away makes
sense
now where is she going
do you think anisha's idea if the queen
moves is to drop his Rook back and yes
in his mind David trying to be but after
rookie for Knight F4 just wins I was
just trying to look for convoluted ways
of getting that draw that Nish uh would
probably like in this position
okay the queen does move okay so this
move we mentioned attacking the queen
yeah it doesn't work because of
Lawrence's night move
uh hitting the queen and hitting the
Rook
so we're looking for something else and
okay he's really trying to get rid of
all the tension swapping off pieces and
grabbing a pawn Onish maybe we've been
too harsh Being Greedy here
it shows ambition he's won a pawn
he's attacking this guy as well
yeah maybe maybe it's fine uh the
knight's never trapped because it can
always Retreat to this Square uh Black's
Queen now going back to defend this pawn
and anisha's one
bit of a smash and grab that one he's
won a Pawn on the edge of the board he
only has three minutes on the clock
though Magnus
almost 12 minutes left on the clock
do you think this will end up with a
winner in this game
I have a feeling there are some uh
twists and turns ahead but it's hard to
say in whose favor that might be
we do know Anish here is maybe the
hardest player in top chess to beat yeah
he hardly ever loses
normally when he doesn't want to lose
he'll find a way to survive he's very
tenacious he's
he very rarely blunders in one move
but yeah it's still that's true a lot of
life left normally when he loses it's
because he's pushing and then he kind of
pulls the brakes at the wrong time and
then it rebounds and uh talking about
Anish blundering I mean this is a very
critical moment in the game because
there's a big threat on the board right
the bishop can calm down and grab a pawn
yeah he's got to be careful if he moves
a rook for example then maybe you'll
move your Banker mm-hmm
I think it works taking this pawn and if
the king moves you've actually put the
King on a bad square and
this is an idea you mentioned quite a
lot earlier the queen on the long
diagonal it's a check next move the
Knight will drop
so you've given up your Bishop but in
return you get a knight in a pawn and
you've ruined the white king position
less than two minutes now for Anish
yeah yeah he's way down on the clock
actually look he's 10 minutes behind and
actually
you know this is the danger of playing
like this as well with white you get
into these tricky positions where you
suddenly need to calculate you burn a
bunch of time and I think Magnus is
going to be relatively happy here
actually and here he comes here we go
here we go
Anish has calculated this he's hoping on
that he can I think swap off the Queens
either hit blocking now or by pushing
his Pawn forward first I thought pushing
the pawn forward me pushing the pawn and
for example if Magnus swaps the Queen's
off then this will go into a dead drawn
Rook end game three pawns versus three
pawns easy draw if Magnus wants to win
he's got to play uh this move Rook takes
still prefer black though because of the
king being a bit weak but a niche
doesn't push his Pawn in the center he
tries to offer the queen exchange and
Magnus says yes Magnus allows the Queens
to come off
and Niche is close to the draw now
surely
still a bit difficult for white because
all four pawns are isolated black has
one porn Island they will defend each
other the wall but uh Whites Whites far
from solid there
shouldn't be enough to with just Rooks
on the board no it looks like a drawer
looks like a niche has got what he
wanted
are you surprised Magnus took the Queens
off
I thought maybe you would try and keep
them on if possible maybe it just wasn't
easy
yeah
um yeah d5's a good move here that's it
that's the way to play giving up a pawn
but uh he's just swapping off some of
his weaknesses
yeah
that's what I was thinking you can
try and Pen maybe not necessarily win
yeah if and if she gets time to trade
off another set of Pawns it should be a
draw especially if one set of Rooks
leave the board three versus two on the
same side is quite straightforward
uh it's very Elementary okay this is the
move the only ambitious move Magnus
doesn't look too ambitious though just
grimacing
this is a pin on the fifth rank but the
white Rook can move this is another pin
and
we're headed towards the drawer Black's
gonna be a pawn up but you can't create
a passport in simply three versus two
Anish will then be on 20 points and the
big question is can David on Tom win in
round 14 he is playing with the white
pieces against Arjun or a guy see that
is the big threat for Anish giri
and also if he loses in the last round
then beat it can also go past him with a
win in the last round yeah I Regice he's
doing him a favor at the moment though
beating David Anton hmm
so uh Anish looks like the stars are
aligning for him he's still a big
favorite going into that last round
we're assuming this is a draw just
because black has
no real way to make progress as soon as
the black king pops its head out it's
going to get checked and kicked away as
soon as black starts pushing pawns that
will just lead to exchanges actually
having split pawns here for white and
not next to each other helps because
it's harder for black to create a
passport in these types of end games
Magnus will try
not sure for how long but
he'll try and push for a while
I don't really see a winning plan for
black in these uh these positions either
I think in a classical game in a long
game if any had more than two minutes
Magnus would just play five moves and
agree to draw and actually we have a
result it's a loss for David Anton
to Arjun Eric icy that means David Anton
is now stuck on 16 points and can Max
get 19 points if he wins in the next one
and each is about to go up to 20.
so that means it's going to be beat it
or Anish we that he has to win then in
the last round and he needs to Hope
Anish loses right because uh Head to
Head
to check that two minutes ago yeah
exactly yeah because uh we did lost to
Anish so
read it ananish are the two players that
will be fighting for the eighth place
yeah so Anish he'll do the calculations
right after this game assuming he draws
he'll realize that he just needs to draw
in the final round
although also Vince
Vincy Winston this
and in the next one he will also have 21
points
and Anish and Vincent Drew and Vincent
against
then if it's three players
he lost to read it well that probably
means read it
if they're all on 21 points
but a niche beat fit it and oh wait
that's true so then it goes to the it's
like a circle yeah and then it goes to
the most wins uh okay
right so we need our sparkly calculator
out yeah where's my glittery calculator
I know we need tie back bring tie back
on
we'll ask Ty about the details after
this round but uh David Anton using in
this round means uh he's out of
contention Anish Geary is probably on 20
points after this round and um did it he
is on 18 points after this round he
already finished
one round left to play
yeah and the same game I guess
I guess to say uh White has got the
perfect defensive formation
Black's King is Advanced but it's still
cut off and and you can just wait
any pawn Advance any pawn exchanges just
guide the game closer to the draw
Lawrence
have you ever had 10 games like this
yeah yeah I I have had end games like
this
um very difficult to lose uh you really
have to try hard to to mess this one up
Anish is just far too good to spoil this
maybe there's one or two little tricks
all there
no there is
no because even for example after King
G3 here David let's say let's say you
play the move G5 which you don't really
want to play but just to illustrate
takes takes let's say white now plays
the move far well he would go down to
the back I guess probably go behind and
start checking but just even if you go
Rook C4 let's just say well let's say
black now plays F4 check King H3 Rook F2
you know I'll play here Lawrence
F4 yeah this is very nice the problem is
it's stalemate this is beautiful but
even if white goes passive for example
um this is still a draw yeah your trick
was to take this exactly yeah but
unfortunately this check would go to a
drawn King and Pauline game this is a
drawstring as the king is in front of
the pawn
and uh eventually Magnus will have to
try something like that but
even if we try and trick white it
doesn't quite work
and yeah unfortunately you can't attack
this Pawn with your Rook that's the
other uh issue right now
that's why Magnus was trying to sneak
behind perhaps but Anish says no
I'm defending the spawn and
just nothing else to do apart from push
your pawns exchange off weaknesses for
white
and two versus one easy draw now
still no way through and I think we're
going to see Magnus try a few more moves
before admitting defeat in his winning
attempts
meanwhile I'm just
ified Magic we've got the sparkly
calculator I'm going to do some maths
yes take it away guys
we're gonna need it now Anish giri on 20
after this game probably is going to be
between him read it and maybe Vincent
kaimer if Vincent is able to win in this
round he is currently playing against
Hare Krishna or chances do you who do
you think right now will be the one
taking the spot number eight David
mathematically I've I've done I've
crunched the numbers
he's in pole position he's still got his
fate in his own hands if he draws this a
win in the last round he's there the
others have to win and Hope so um
all of my tournaments whenever I'm in
those situations relying on other other
results you don't feel any certainty
and okay and she's going behind with the
White Rock now he's going to draw this
game give a few checks and I should of
course also mention naroditsky who is
also on 15 points if he also wins
both in this round and the next round he
will also be on 21 points but the bar is
over to do that side in that game and if
he loses it's over for nardisky these
are the current standings a few games
have finished Bunch still going on and
we do see a niche on 19 about to go up
to 20 points needed 18 David Anton
losing it's over for him he will uh he's
stuck now on 16 points but Vincent
climber and narditski on 15 still
fighting for points in this round
and I think we're going to see a draw
any moment uh the player's repeating
moves
do we have a result there there we go
Anish might feel like he got away with
one yeah shaking his head he is
definitely aware that this does not
secure his spot in The Knockout stage he
needs point in the final round as well
and in that final round who will Anish
giri play